Speaker 1: we have a voicemail number, which
you can call any time of day. That number is
two one nine two. David P.. Today, I have sort of
a it's almost like a political f Mary kill. It's
kind of a weird voicemail. Let's listen to it.
Speaker 3: Hello. Imagine that. Let's say you're
on a stranded island, OK? And you have some people
with you now. You can choose from five people.
And the five people are Kyle Kalinowski and
Davilla, John Eider Rola. And a kasparian.
Jan Kuga, and you can only choose three of
those people to be with you on the island.
Speaker 1: Wow. OK, listen, I get that this is
a joke, but here's my thought. If my so one of
these people I don't know who it is, Neander Nando
Velar, I think he said I don't know who that is.
So listen, there's no right way to do this.
Right. But I'm going to first just stick with
the people I know. That leaves us, Kyle John from
Twitter and from Twitty and Genk. Now, I don't.
I I've never met John in person, Kyle, Anna and
Genk are people I've known for a long time, and
this is not a criticism of John.
John's a great guy, as far as I know,
from our social media interactions. But if I
was given these choices on the desert island,
I'm saving Kyle. I'm saving Anna and I'm
saving Genk, these are not reflections of any
political agreement or disagreement on any issue
in particular, I don't even know anything about
that. It's just those are the three I've met.
So those are the three I'm saving on the desert
island. All right, guys, but that would be a
grim situation. That would be a grim situation
regardless. All right. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. Consumer prices are actually
rose less than expected in August. This seemingly
is a good sign if you were one of the inflation
spiral fear mongers. But they're coming up.
They're moving the goalposts as they often do.
Also, you might remember this program, cops,
when I was growing up, this program, cops,
was very, very popular. And the program
has been pulled because of a combination of
seeming to sometimes kind of glorify police
violence and being seemingly problematic in other
ways in terms of different things. Anyway, the
program is apparently being brought back by Fox
Nation. So we're going to talk about that on the
bonus show today. And also, Apple's co-founder has
announced the private space company to clean up
the space debris that is increasingly in our skies
above us. Very interesting new project, Steve
Wozniak. We are going to talk about all three
of those stories and more on today's bonus
show. Don't miss it really, guys. Don't miss
that. Sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom and we
will see you then. Otherwise, we will be back
with a new show tomorrow. But my preference
would be I would love to see you on the boat.